I like that we have this lazy susan
thing you want the most air you eat
cover your food that you're covering a
test here we cover your death like that
[ __ ] off you all right so today oh it's
Jay King Newsday today and it's a Monday
the reason why we're doing Jay King news
on a Monday there's Joe he's flying out
of town soon and so we need to make up
for the Thursday that he's gonna be gone
for and I've been called in for the
morning session and I leave when I'm
ready to pick up Isaac but that means
for you is that it's Isaac and daddy day
mm-hmm cool how rather JJ news days on
Monday yeah so for Tuesdays and
Thursdays I can always see mommy
you never see mommy on Tuesdays and
Thursdays loser filming days mm-hmm
that's true so I have all the days you
would wanted to be out on Monday yep
creating the ideal work schedule from JK
is probably one of the hardest things
because we want to be flexible but yet
we still need structure well things like
going to school you know like all that
stuff revolves around our 9 to 5
schedule so we try balance you know
[Music]
all right you ready yeah let's go daddy
is so or 2016
oh is it isn't that a new thing anymore
[Music]
all right so I just finished taking
Isaac to school came back got dressed
TIFF is already out the door so I gotta
get over there myself
[Music]
I'm in next to you I know we
unintentionally match it's always like a
bring your spouse to work because even
though yeah we work in the same company
we don't always get to work together
yeah we're in different departments or
in the keep the youtubes going
Department and I'm in the S break into
the film world Department so we don't
always get to work together so that's
why I really like it when you come and
you visit me for news and plus people
love you too especially with your laughs
you're like Casey's laughs gives this
video like rocks the feeling I get about
that I feel like a hot girl that doesn't
offer very much other than hotness so
I'm the guy that doesn't offer very much
head in the laughs I'm gonna do today
without laughing
I'm gonna be like why is Casey there
like why is even in this episode what
happened to gave me where's this dolphin
left so what's the hold up we've been
here for like we're gonna be filming
soon though I sure brought my stuff I
didn't bring anything so you brought
your camera that's your stuff too yeah
shaking you said just trying to prep for
the next one that's what I'm trying to
do you got a this just in
yeah so last night there was a shooting
in Vegas and it just happened so jess is
writing notes for me and we have to film
it before we break for lunch cuz ken is
gonna come and pick it up edit it and
then have it ready by tomorrow hopefully
so we're trying to get the story out as
soon as possible with the amount of
information that's coming out but then
she's just texting me right now saying
that there's so much information that's
coming out that kind of contradicts the
information that has been outside like
there's many different sources yeah I
for sure I already know this is gonna be
one that people are not gonna be happy
about with me like two if you didn't do
all your research I tried doing it
[Music]
[Applause]
lunchtime at JK news tiny a chicken yeah
you got tired of hainan chicken oh yeah
I had to get chicken pasta so every time
we filmed on news we always have options
from the same two restaurants and that's
because I guess people are just used to
you know it's brainless it's just kind
of fill out the full it's uh uh my brain
dinner I should eat I think some more so
good it's like the most amount of garlic
I've ever smelled in pasta melt I
smelled smelt
well that's garlicky all right oh yeah I
have so much work to finish during lunch
that I don't even have an appetite like
I'm hungry but I have an appetite so I'm
just gonna wait until later I'm eating
this cuz I'm bored because I failed to
bring a laptop to work on anything so I
have nothing to do and I also finished
this coffee so my appetite isn't here I
don't know about you guys but for me I'm
the kind of person if I start eating I
end up getting hungry because that
happened to you guys because I'm just so
concentrate on work day even though I'm
hungry I'm so preoccupied by trying to
finish the thing that I'm doing but then
the moment I eat I get really hungry
been that before no forget to eat like
I'll like skip a meal and then it'll be
like 1:00 in the morning he'd be like oh
that's right what's this weird feeling
my stomach that's right food oh cool
yeah we recently uploaded a video where
I was pressing for news last week and in
that video cuz it just came out today I
was reading some comments and people
were saying why is Hulya no longer
hosting news would you like to answer
oh I mean we need to make a post on it
up on my Instagram I was actually
thinking about that today like while
we're filming like I should probably
make that post no make a youtube video
right here eagerly waiting for your next
YouTube video oh that's got me oviparous
woo
no longer hosting I've been doing it for
a while and I think for me you it's just
I wanted to do something else because I
kind of wanted to step back and be more
into like the production side then I
guess there's like a lot of things in
the company that needed to be filled so
I'm filling those positions and I don't
really want to give them away but the
only thing I could give away is that I'm
doing rich now so yeah I should took
over Wow so I took over at merch took
over mature me game hmm I took over
merch but I am also doing another thing
which I don't really want to say just
after it yeah secret I was told that
like there are other positions in the
company that needs to be filled and that
they would prefer if somebody in-house
would fill them in so that's where I'm
at because every week I would see you're
so stressed out and like so like looking
like you so I told you I'm like hey you
know it's okay like I don't mind taking
over completely for me hosting JK news
was like a blessing because it just came
to me at like at a time when it needed
to be filled in and I just filled in
that spot because of like hey put me in
wherever you guys need me because like I
just want to help the company out and I
think like we just come to the point
where it's just like we're you know like
either one of us could just completely
take over and I think for me it's like
I've been doing it so long that like I
feel like stories don't really see me as
much anymore and I feel like I'm not as
enthusiastic and like I think because
they all sound the same everything just
starts blending together in my head so
I'm just like wait is that the story
we're talking about now or is it like
before yeah so like it just got a little
confusing I think from you it's just
like well I feel like it's time to move
on yeah true do other things that's the
reason why kuna no longer hosts for me
personally I've been living in the
bubble all my life and I just feel like
I don't have enough life experiences
like everyone else around the table so I
just feel like I don't really have much
stories to say and if I did I've already
said them on the channel and I just feel
like I kept puttin as much input and I
don't have much of an opinion because I
just feel very neutral for a lot of
things but it's not as strong as like
how everybody else feels so I just feel
like yeah that I'm probably best suited
behind I feel yeah I I feel exactly that
every time I'm here too
I mean you do so well oh I'm okay so
like sometimes when I hear the stories
though it's not that interesting and
it's like so sure okay what's next but
there's definitely a lot less pressure
behind camera absolutely
oh yeah absolutely you risk very little
when you're behind the camera I think
that's one of the things that most
people don't understand either is a
demonise tip in front of the camera and
you're trying to be something you know
whether you're helping people entertain
people make people laugh make people sad
sing a song whatever you put yourself
out there to be ridiculed the love be
hated and it's so there's a lot of
pressure and for me too it's like I feel
way more comfortable vlogging from
behind the camera and talking like
everything like this and blah blah blah
blah blah blah for the moment this is
happening it changes everything I don't
know it's all psychological all right
morning session is over
yeah now it's a second session time so
meet my replacement hello Stacy volume
2.0 yes I'm 5.0 there oh yeah you'll be
original oh but no 2.0 is better than
1.0 this year that's how those things
work okay I didn't mean that then
scratch that it's always fun to be part
of JK news I noticed over the years that
uh part of our group of friends don't we
don't hang out as often as we used to I
think it's just because we're all
getting older we're all getting busier
we all have our own individual lives now
we're all settling down with significant
others and we're starting a family
so we're naturally not hanging out as
often and because of that I'm I'm even
more grateful for jakie news because
it's the ijk news it's kind of like an
excuse to work and hang out
simultaneously because we don't we don't
ever kick it and have fun you know so JK
news is kind of like that all wrapped up
into work I think that's the coolest
thing about JK news that
really just hanging out with each other
but simultaneously were able yes
something productive done so that's
always really cool anyways I am on my
way to pick up Isaac Thursday nights are
always just me and Isaac and we have a
evening to ourselves patiently waiting
for TIFF to finish taking news and when
she gets home she'll probably tuck eyes
again for bed hey Amy and I are playing
video games yeah yeah what are we going
right now Oh play plants vs. zombies
that one's me that one's Isaac
I got a play I'm standing still done
good go
all right so finish playing video games
and totally got bored with video games
I'm not much of a gamer myself but in
small doses I think about 15 minutes of
time I think I can hang I think we did
about 30 minutes just now now we're
gonna cook but first I wanted to shout
out this cutting board this cutting
board was given to me by my good friend
for my wedding present Kevin Lee and he
was actually the guy that was speaking
at the wedding right before my brother
spoke and I grew up with him we met each
other when we were five and so it's just
crazy that you know we've known each
other for our entire lives and you know
we're still right now for each other so
pretty cool and this is probably the
baddest tightest wedding gift I've
received from anyone and then scattered
tnc the the date of our wedding and his
initials and that's a pretty solid piece
of work I like it anyway it's time to
make dinner
[Music]